Hello!
Good morning everybody!
Sorry, we looted because I wanted to put on the pilot hat.
Sorry, the only reason why we looted was I was like, oh my god!
I should put on a hat!
And I was trying to find a hat.
I was trying to find a hat for the immersion!
I was trying to find a hat and that's why we looted today.
It's important!
The hat was so important!
You guys don't understand!
How can I be a real pilot if I don't have the hat?
Also, oh my god!
Lemo, thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you!
Guys, I'm so incredibly tired.
I'm so... I... I...
I...
I was like, I could do 11.30.
It's just like 12.30 but like an hour earlier.
And then I woke up at 11.15 and I was like realizing it's not like 12.30.
I woke up like, oh... it's not like 12.30.
It's... why?
It's so much worse.
So...
So... good morning, everybody!
Good morning!
The reason why... The reason why my stream is an hour earlier is because I have a meeting with YouTube!
I was... Originally I had a meeting with YouTube to just like be like welcoming me on YouTube.
Or like welcoming me back on YouTube.
So...
So, originally, originally, I was supposed to meet with the YouTube people, like, maybe a month ago.
But then, because of daylight savings, the meeting got scuffed.
Like, it got really scuffed, so we had to postpone it.
Because we weren't able to attend the meeting because of daylight savings a month ago.
And now, like, our schedules lined up.
Our schedules finally lined up today.
So, I was like... it was a debate.
I was like, do I do this... I didn't miss it!
I didn't miss it!
Our meetings got, like, super scuffed up.
Okay, I'm just gonna say it was daylight savings time, but I didn't miss it.
We just had to reschedule it.
So, we had to reschedule it.
And today's the day I get to meet Mr. YouTube himself.
Oh my god, a real person.
I think, like, one of the funniest...
Like, first... the first email we got from YouTube was like, Hello!
I'm a real person.
I remember, like, when my manager sent me the email, it was like, Oh hey, YouTube wants to meet you.
And then, like, I think the first or second sentence was like, Hi, I'm a real person.
But I really... I like the... our YouTube guy.
He's really nice.
Because, like, I had issues.
I don't know if I told you guys, but, like, the second channel thing was solved.
Like, my Twitch... my Twitch vlogs channel.
There was an issue with my Twitch vlogs channel.
Did I... did I tell this in the members?
I told this in the members, right?
Okay.
Did I tell this in the members or... members.
Yes, I told this in the members.
It's because I... I leaked something in the members.
So, for those who are not in the members... in the members stream, what happened was that my Twitch vlogs channel...
Look, everything, like, blurs together.
Like, all... my entire life has been, like, stream...
Like, I feel like... like, a lot... I feel like majority of my brain space has just been, like, filled up with streaming stuff.
That I don't know what is what anymore.
I don't know.
I was like, did I say this in the members?
Did I say this in my past channel?
Did I say this in my current channel?
I'm like, I don't know what I said.
Did I say this in my past channel, members?
I can't remember.
There's too many things to take into account now.
It's getting more complicated.
It's getting so much more complicated now.
So...
So, anyway...
Basically, what happened...
For those who are, like, super confused and are like, oh, what happened?
Basically, my Twitch vlogs channel...
It was, like...
It succeeded in monetization.
Not for, like, ads yet.
I still need, like, I think, like, 30 more hours of watch time.
30 more hours of watch time.
Hint, hint.
To get to be able to monetize via ads.
But I can turn on super chats and members in my second Twitch...
Sorry, my second YouTube channel.
Which I won't do because I think that's a little stupid because it's a VODS channel.
But I wanted to, like, make sure my...
Make sure it's already approved for monetization already.
So, like, just to be, like...
Just to do it in advance.
And...
And then...
So, I applied for monetization on my Twitch VODS...
My VODS channel.
And then...
I got rejected.
And I was, like...
I was, like...
What?
Why did I get rejected?
It's...
It's a VODS channel.
So, I looked at the requirements.
And then the requirements was, like...
They, like...
Why did they reject me?
And then, apparently, one of them was that...
They didn't know if it was me.
Or it was, like, an impersonation.
Or something.
Like, they thought, like...
Oh, somebody was...
Might be impersonating me.
And they're, like...
Oh, if you're gonna re-upload somebody else's content...
You gotta make sure it has, like, different things on there.
Like, you gotta make it your own.
You gotta edit it in a way that's your own.
And I was, like...
What the fuck?
So...
So, they're, like...
Okay, if you wanna send an appeal...
Prove that this is you.
And so, I was, like...
Okay...
I'm gonna, I guess...
Cause I know you can monetize VOD's channel...
Due to, like, my experiences.
My previous experiences.
I know you can monetize, like...
VOD's channel.
So, then I was, like...
Okay...
Um...
I'm...
I basically...
What I leaked was the video I sent.
The...
It has to be transformed.
It was, like...
The video I sent...
Um...
Uh...
I sent in the members.
So, like...
I let the members hear what I said.
And then...
And so, like...
I made a video.
I had to make it unlisted.
And then I made a video being, like...
Hi...
Um...
This is me.
This is my channel.
Here's my main channel.
And here's my Twitch channel.
So, like...
You can tell this is me.
And then, like...
I sent that in.
I was, like...
Here's all the...
Like...
I is me.
I'm Doki Bird.
This is all me.
And then I sent it in.
And then they rejected it.
And was, like...
We don't...
We're, like...
We don't know if this is you.
And I was, like...
What do you mean?
You don't know if it's me.
I literally said, it's me.
Like...
What do you mean?
It's not me.
And so, like...
They rejected the appeal.
And then...
I had to e-mail my YouTube guy.
And I was, like...
What the fuck is going on?
I was, like...
Why did they reject me?
It's me.
And my YouTube guy, like...
Got...
Like...
Was, like...
Don't worry.
I got this.
I'll make...
I'll talk to them myself.
I got you.
And so, like...
And the day after...
I remember.
I think, like...
A day after they remonetized it.
They were, like...
You're good to go.
You're in the program now.
They're, like...
You're good to go.
You're in the program now for your second channel.
And I was, like...
Yay!
That's all you have to do.
You gotta get a YouTube guy.
E-mail them.
Be, like...
What the fuck?
And then they'll, like...
Don't worry.
Yay!
I'm so happy.
Oh, my God.
So, second channel...
Monetized.
Anyway.
I have a meeting.
That's the reason why the stream is starting earlier.
I like how, like...
Already, like...
Talk for 14 minutes now.
But I still have more stuff to talk about.
So, I'm so sorry for the EU goons who are, like...
Doki, please.
We have so limited time together.
This is the only stream we could watch this week.
And everything.
Reasonable time, Doki, please play the game.
I'm sorry, but like I'm gonna keep talking
Doki, my connecting flight, please start the plane!
anyway, so that's why I have a I have a meeting at 2 p.m And I debate between like either streaming at 3 or streaming an hour earlier because you know If I stream at my usual time, I can only do like, you know, not that much and I was just like I don't want to rush it I don't want to rush it I don't wanna because it would be like a lesson to our stream and I was like we don't really have a stream for the EU goons This week so I was like,
oh my gosh all the other slots were sort of taken So I was like, okay Like I said all the other time slots were taken like all the other slots were taking when I'm like an indie now so I control my own schedule We schedule something because of something here or like overlapping or anything because there's literally no overlaps for me anymore But like anyway as I was saying there was no more time slots for me to put it in So I was like I might as well put this at 11 with this one at 1130
Anyway Anyway I got some like oh my gosh I'm like super happy today because I actually woke up to some really good news today.
I can't say what but like I could say like a lot of my dreams are coming true, and I'm just I'm just really happy.
I'm just so happy!
I mean I'm just happier.
But it's super exciting it's super duper exciting.
I'm like really excited about the oncoming news.
Anyway, flight simulator.
I've always wanted to try this game out.
I feel like I'm gonna yell that a lot though.
I feel like I'm gonna get yelled at so much because it's so...
I was like looking at the settings and I was like what the fuck?
Because it's like super immersive and I'm just like oh man.
Oh no.
This game might be too easy because of how because of how immersive it is and how obviously amazing I am at flying.
I was like oh man.
This is so much fun.
This game could just be too fucking easy.
Oh no!
Oh my god, anyway.
I don't know.
I feel I'm a bit scared for those who are wondering.
I'm still not using my I'm still not using my new PC because it's a lot to set up for and um The new PC there's a lot of stuff I need to do to set up for it And I really I haven't had the time to actually like sit down and Sit down and like, you know transfer everything over.
I feel like I think I will like do that at another time Maybe like when I have maybe like more rest days at the moment.
So I guess we're gonna stress test my my current PC which we don't really need a stress test because we can like you know, we can we can sort of understand how stressed the PC already is.
So...
I feel like I have to change these settings.
I don't know These settings seem pretty..
you know... I don't know I'm worried I'm so worried Okay Do we really?
I don't know man, okay We're gonna try those settings that we're gonna do a Default what what's the words that could happen?
Default Thanks Superchat did you can thank you if you could do a forklift And a plane would be easy to give a superstar Thank you.
Also, I saw that you guys... good eye.
I don't know if you guys know this, but it's one of my four birthdays.
Or is it five birthdays?
I already lost track of my own lore.
Thank you.
Yes, it's one of my four of the five birthdays.
Very good eye.
Thank you.
It's my birthday, guys.
Real.
Alright, how do you play this?
What do we do?
Do we do flight training?
I guess we should do flight training, right?
Or do we go straight into it?
I feel like I already have enough flight training, guys.
Right?
What mode should we do?
World map?
Do we do world... I feel like world map is gonna fucking kill my PC.
Okay, but what if we do like a discovery flight?
And what if we go to New York City?
Okay, we shouldn't go to New York City.
I just realized the implications.
What if we do like... I don't know.
The island here.
The Bora Bora.
Alright.
We'll do Bora Bora and then...
I don't know.
The Skyhawk?
Bro, what the fuck?
What the fuck is a Skyhawk?
Okay.
I wanna... I wanna do a real plane.
Is that a real plane?
That's a real plane.
Alright, here we go.
The real plane time.
Why the fuck is it showing me a controller?
This is all M and K.
Uh...
HS, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy 1 to 4 to 5 birthday.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Happy birthday.
Alright, here we go.
What is this?
What is it?
I'm gonna teach you guys how to be a real pilot.
Also, is Sound Guy even here?
What plane is this?
Um...
Does it tell me what plane it is?
The... Air 3501.
Wait, that's not... I wanna be in the cockpit.
Oh ho.
Guys...
Am I flying?
Oh my god, look.
I'm already doing it already.
Uh...
Guys...
I think I'm... My altitude is slowly going down.
How do I... How do I pull up?
I thought I would be given more instructions.
How do I pull up?
Why am I looking down here?
Okay.
Guys, we're gonna watch the slowest fucking crash.
Why is it turning?
How do I...
AHHHHH THIS IS WORSE!
THIS IS WORSE!
Okay, I'm...
AHHHHH!
Alright, we're not going... we're not doing that anymore.
Oh my god, I don't know how to change my face.
I accidentally pressed it.
I don't know how to re-change my face.
I don't remember my face.
I don't remember how to use my face, guys.
I don't remember how to use my face.
Give me a sec, everybody.
Give me a sec.
Alright, turning that off.
Turning my face off real quick, guys.
Gotta turn that off.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, okay.
I realized... guys, I realized...
We're gonna need to do the tutorial.
We need to do basic handling.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Your pilot's got this.
Introduction... we're gonna... we're gonna go through a basic course through this.
It can't be that difficult.
Alright, we can't... it can't be that difficult.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
Maybe just a little bit of tutorial would be helpful.
I don't know why, but like, maybe just a little bit of a tutorial.
Bacon, thank you for the acca-soupa!
Thank you, thank you!
10 out of 10.
Fastest flight I ever had.
Was a little concerned when a pilot asked how to fly, but they landed on a really nice coffee fountain.
So it's all good.
Yeah!
See?!
That guy gets it!
There was no fire!
There was no fire, so everything was okay.
Hello.
Hello, Jess.
Why are we starting on the ground?
It's a plane.
It should be in the sky.
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, it looks pretty nice.
The ASXGS.
Look at that!
Oh my god, that's me!
There's another person in my plane!
It's my twin!
They trust me so much they put another... Look!
I'm not a bad pilot!
If I was a bad pilot, why would they put another person in my plane?
Okay, open the basic controls pad...
Oh!
Not controller!
Give me a second.
Let me grab my controller.
Apparently, this is on.
I'm on it!
What?
Okay, guys.
Alright, I'm plugging in my controller.
Because apparently I have to use a controller.
I was like, what do you mean?
I can't even change the layout!
Alright.
We have to... Okay, and apply... Okay, yes.
Keep default.
Alright, we're good to go.
This can't be that bad now.
What the fuck is a rudder?
Toggle, increase throttle... Oh, brakes!
We need to know that.
Increase flaps.
Oh my god.
Guys, I think being a pilot is very... I don't know, guys.
I think it's trying to tell me that being a pilot might be a little difficult.
When you're on the plane and you hear your pilot say, guys, how do I fly over the intercom?
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, how do I get out of here?
Okay.
I got it.
I opened the cam... Opened the camera panel.
Oh my god, I'm dual wielding.
Camera.
I wanna be... Oh, it says track IP.
I was like, what?
Okay, I wanna be in the cockpit.
Can I change what my pilot looks like?
Was it pilot?
Landing?
Co-pilot?
No, I wanna be my pilot.
Okay.
Now I'm super immersive.
Yeah.
I can turn on the cabin light.
How do I... Point the yoke and hide it?
What the fuck is a yoke?
Oh, is this a yoke?
Oh, okay.
Wait, I can turn on... Oh my god, I can turn on strobe lights?
Oh my god, there's so many things.
How do I... How do I turn this off?
.
Okay, that's cool.
Oh, that's why we have a co-pilot.
So like, if I fuck up, they can like, take the wheel.
Okay.
I'm trying to...
Guys, I'm trying.
Trying so hard.
Guys, okay.
Taxi lights.
Okay.
Um...
Oh, the cursor point thing... Where the...
What?
Okay, guys.
Where's...
Guys, where's the yoke?
Where's the yoke?
Okay, but like, oh my god, I can turn on these lights though.
There it is.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
I can have all the lights on.
I am pressing A.
I'm pressing A!
Are we leaving?
Sir, please be patient!
Oh, yoke!
Yo- It's this button!
It's right here!
Wait, what?
Wait, I saw the yoke!
Where was the yoke?
I... Oh, wait.
I saw it again!
There it is.
Oh my god, that's the yoke.
That's the yoke.
Yoke!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's...
Wait, but it... Okay, lock the cursor.
Lock the knob by pressing A.
Okay, did I lock it?
Did I lock it?
Um...
Am I locking?
Instructor?
Am I... Instructor, please.
I'm pressing... Instructor, please.
I'm trying.
Where?
Wait, I should, like, hide this one too.
Instructor, it's not letting me lock!
Teacher!
It's not...
I'm trying!
Oh!
It's, like, right here!
You have to click exactly this tiny-ass thing!
Okay, that seems like the right time.
See?
Oh, I need to know my time.
As a pilot, you don't need to know what time it is.
If they're late, they're late.
We can...
They'll never blame the pilot for being late.
They'll blame the airlines.
Um, Aura, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
My flightless blur!
Thank you for the super chat!
Okay, hold LB and move the camera around.
I'm holding.
Okay.
Oh, that was not LB, sorry.
Alright, I'm using... Oh.
What?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I think I like...
Alright, save a custom view.
There you go.
Alright.
We're so... We're so... We're so locked in.
Guys, we're really locked in now.
Okay, I'm gonna go make sure we're... We're high... We're lower.
Alright.
So I can just see the controls.
I like that.
Yeah.
This one... I like this height.
Press LB and save using... Yeah.
It's not saved?
Save.
Save?
Okay,
I don't think... Okay, I don't think they let me have that as a custom.
Okay.
Save.
Save?
Oh, there we go.
Save.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
And then LB, Y...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I want this to be my custom though.
Try to familiarize yourself with them a bit more.
There you go.
This is the perfect.
Then reset the camera to its original position whenever you're done.
Okay.
Reset.
Alright, done.
Great.
I did it!
That's it?
That was...
Okay.
Guys!
I got an A!
I'm ready to fly!
I think I'm ready to fly.
Honestly.
Honestly, after all that...
Yes.
I think I'm ready.
I figured it out.
Guys.
I fucking figured it out.
Alright.
We're gonna...
Let's go to...
Alright, let's see.
Seattle.
I wanna go see the...
I wanna see the fucking space needle.
Alright, fly.
And then...
Wait.
Arrival...
And then we depart...
From...
I don't know where this is.
What state is that?
I don't know.
There we go.
Fly!
We're so ready.
We're so fucking ready now.
I got an A!
My instructor said I got an A!
Chat.
How...
How badly can I fuck up now?
I can't fuck up if the instructor gave me an A.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
It's just me.
Okay.
Guys, it's okay.
It's just me.
Alright.
Release the parking brake.
Apply throw throttle.
Okay.
Watch this, guys.
We're gonna...
I like to have...
I'm gonna turn off the visibility here.
And then we're gonna turn on all the lights.
Boop.
Okay.
And then we gotta have...
We gotta have the cabin light on and everything.
And then...
What the fuck is an alternator?
That's a gun.
And then we're gonna do...
I think we're good.
I think...
I think we're good to go.
Alright.
Throw full throttle time.
Woo.
Am I...
How do I go forward?
That should be full throttle.
Oh!
I'm going forward!
Alright.
Looks good.
I think we're good.
And then we go up.
Okay.
Am I going straight?
Seems alright.
I'll eventually fly up.
Because of the velocity.
Right?
Raise it higher and lift up.
Oh!
I'm flying!
Oh my god!
Oh!
I'm flying!
Guys!
Did you see that!
I was in the air!
Guys!
Did you see that!
I flew!
Oh my...
Oh my god!
I flew!
I'm a natural.
I knew I could do it.
Okay guys.
I think I need another lesson.
I need...
Okay.
I think...
Alright guys.
I think I need another lesson here.
I learned about yoke and reading basic... I don't need to read basic instructions.
Okay, maybe I do.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, what a hell of a way to die.
You're not dead!
Nothing exploded!
It was just a minor inconvenience.
It was just minor inconvenience, chat.
Nobody... everybody's okay.
So dramatic.
Okay.
We're learning.
Slowly but surely.
You should give me like a bigger aircraft.
I wanna drive this tiny-ass plane.
Alright.
Thank you, instructor.
Yeah.
I'm getting on board for these flights.
Breezy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I flew!
Okay.
I'm doing the yoke to see the effect on the ailerons.
Oh my god, do you see that?
The ailerons?
Okay.
Do you see that?
It's moving up and down!
I'm doing that!
The difference between the yoke and a steering wheel is you can pull or push on the yoke.
This controls the elevator at the back of the aircraft to make it climb or descend.
This guy trusts me.
Look at him.
Look at the horizontal stabilizer.
They're like my bodyguards.
You can see how it affects the elevator.
The what?
The elevator?
Is that called an elevator?
Truly a former Air Command Airport hero.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're on the ground.
The upper part of the pedals also control your brakes.
Oh my god.
Wait, I have brakes?
They control the rudder at the end of the rudder.
Whoa, that's new.
This is for coordinating turns or compensating for a plane's tendency to pull left during takeoffs and climbs.
Wait.
Sorry, what did she say about the rudder?
Is there a reason for brakes?
Look at the vertical tail and then move by using...
And...
By using...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Move by RT and...
Oh, look at that!
It's flapping!
Oh my god, it's saying hi!
Oh!
That's how you turn, right?
Pulling back will decrease power.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Look at the throttle.
Is that the throttle?
This is where I drive!
Keep it selected and push it forward to increase power.
Oh, did I not increase power?
Guys, I think I realized why I crashed.
Guys.
Guys, I think I realized.
Also, thank you flight attendant for telling me to...
For telling me to...
To increase the sound.
And not push it enough?
How much more do you want me to push it?
There you go.
Power is increased.
Now, pull it back to decrease power.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh my god, there's so many things to know.
Where the fuck is my co-pilot?
Deselect the throttle and
increase power.
Look away?
Why do I...
Oh!
I can just hold!
I can just hold it!
Hold B to decrease.
Oh!
I'm doing it.
RPM indicator?
What the fuck is...
Oh!
But that's my co-pilot spot!
Who's gonna tell me about my RPM meter?
The engine is spinning in hundreds of revolutions per minute.
That's so far away from me!
Look at your current speed on the airspeed indicator.
Where's that?
It's on the left in the main instrument panel.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Thank you instructor.
It measures the speed in knots.
I don't even know that.
As long as I go fast, that's all that matters, right?
It's on the right side of the main instrument panel.
Okay.
Alright, dragoons.
You're my co-pilot.
Guys, you gotta make sure we don't crash.
Because if we crash, we both die.
You'd be like, oh, it's so funny.
Don't crash.
You're in the same plane.
We both crash.
Like, it's your fault as well.
That's all for today.
That's it?
Next time, we'll see how it feels in the air.
What?
That's it?
You just... what?
Guys!
Oh my god.
I think I'm ready for real this time.
Guys!
Guys, I think we're ready for real.
Okay, let's like go in the air first.
Okay, I'm gonna... we're gonna try to go in the air.
And then after being in the air, we're definitely ready.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I will go out in the blaze for the content.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I'm in the air!
I did?
Oh my god, I'm in the air.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's beautiful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As someone who works in aviation maintenance, thank you for keeping me employed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it is!
Look at that!
It's so beautiful!
I love how... unrendered this is.
There's an airport?
Where?
Is that an airport?
What the fuck is that?
That's an airport?
Oh, the instructor flies?
What if I don't want you to fly it?
When it was my turn?
That's not fair!
I'm the pilot!
I'm wearing the hat!
That's not fair!
It's like she doesn't trust me!
It's like my fucking co-pilot doesn't trust me!
They don't even let me fly the thing!
I'm gonna turn on the fucking lights.
Oh, I can't.
They just...
They won't even let me turn on the lights!
Why do they disable everything?
Okay.
I wouldn't either.
Oh!
Okay.
Monkey see, monkey do.
Wait, but her thing is not moving!
Oh my god!
Autopilot is on, isn't it?
You can't fool me!
The yoke isn't even moving!
How do I know if it's under 30 degrees?
Which one do I look at for that?
There's just so many... Which one do I look at?
How do I know if it's... Do I have to be outside?
Go ahead and try rolling to the right.
Okay.
How do I know if it's 30 degrees?
I have controls!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna turn on some lights.
Oh, I wanna turn on the pilot heat.
My cushy is cold.
I'm gonna turn on the pilot heat.
And then I'm gonna turn on...
I'm gonna turn on the landing lights.
Because I might be landing soon.
And then the taxi lights.
Alright.
We...
Oh!
We're okay.
See?
We're okay!
Look at that!
We're going to Sedona!
That's like a song, right?
Control movements are soft and gentle.
They were not okay.
As we flank toward Sedona, let's try climbing up and down.
Up and down.
Whoa!
That's it.
Pull on the yoke to climb!
Give it a try.
Yay.
That's climbing, right?
Hold your pitch up for five seconds.
What does that mean?
Excellent.
Oh, okay.
For the descent.
Is the same principle?
Except pushing on the yoke.
Those beeps are not of those beeps you just all scare...
Alright.
Gently push forward.
Forward.
Hold your pitch down for five seconds.
Okay.
I'm so gentle!
Do you guys not see that?
Oh, it's this way.
Guys!
I thought it'd be funny!
Okay, I got a little impatient.
I thought my co-pilot... Guys, I thought my co-pilot would stop me.
I really thought... I really... I really thought... I really thought my co-pilot would stop me!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I had to look at the fucking scenery again!
I thought they would stop me!
What's the point of having a co-pilot if they don't stop you from making stupid decisions?
Your co-pilot is here to stop your intrusive thoughts.
I just think my co-pilot was not doing her job.
They could've fucking... They could've fucking took control of the yoke!
That's not my fault!
They could've literally took control... It's their life too!
It's their life too!
Oh my god, I can turn on the crew volume?
Okay, enjoy the view.
Alright, I'm enjoying the view, guys.
Look at that.
Look at that beautiful airport over there.
It's not my fault my intrusive thoughts won.
What's the point of having a co-pilot if they don't stop you from making terrible decisions?
Like, I might as well be the only person in this plane.
You have 5.2 gig co-pilots and no one... Why did you guys not stop me, huh?
You guys were supposed to be my co-pilots!
Why didn't you guys stop me?
From letting my thoughts win!
Alright.
I still can't read all of these.
There's too many fucking...
meter circle things in front of me.
What's this?
Is this the time?
Oh, so that's how you do the turn.
That's such a smooth turn, man.
Why can't I fly like that?
I can and I will.
I'm gonna prove you all wrong.
JK because I can.
Okay.
How do I know it's 30 degrees?
I'm not good at math.
Can I have access to the plane now?
Okay.
I wanna...
Alright.
Okay.
I'm gonna turn on my... the light.
I'm gonna turn on the heat position.
And then the light.
Here.
What's this red button?
Oooh.
Long time flight simmer.
Very recent dragoon here.
This is fantastic.
Keep up...
See?
This person thinks I'm fucking flying the plane perfectly.
August, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I knew I was doing things right.
If this long-term flight simulator player thinks I'm doing okay, then I'm right and you're wrong.
Fake donating.
Don't enable it.
Gently pull back the yolk to increase the...
Is that gentle?
Next time, be a bit more gentle on the controls.
What do you mean that's so gentle?
For the descent, it's the same principle except you're pushing on the yolk.
Go ahead.
Gently pitch down.
Okay.
I think I'm doing it.
There.
Guys.
We're experiencing some turbulence right now.
This is just turbulence.
Is this what turbulence is?
Look around.
And when you found it, make a turn in that direction.
Oh, wait.
It's this way.
Weeeeee.
Okay.
We gotta go up though when we're turning.
Weeeeee.
This is what turbulence, guys.
We're just experiencing turbulence.
It's not...
It's not man-made error.
It's just turbulence.
Okay.
Captain Doki, we're losing altitude.
Reduce speed to 138 knots and pull up on the yolk.
Oh, Charlie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where the...
Where the fuck's the airport?
Find and turn towards the airport.
Where the fuck is it?
There's just all houses.
Where the fuck build all these houses next to my airport?
Where the fuck is the airport?
Oh my god.
I'm still flying.
I can't see the goddamn airport.
Is that the airport?
Is that the runway?
That's the runway, right?
Guys, where the fuck is the airport?
Is it behind me?
No, that's the airport, right?
Just landing on the port.
No, that's a road?
Oh my god.
Okay.
We're gonna find this goddamn airport.
Turn your head.
Oh!
Oh my god, guys.
I could turn my head.
Okay.
No, that's not the airport.
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
I see the airport!
It was right behind me this entire time!
There you go.
I was like, turn please for the love of god.
Turn your head.
You're flying.
This is like a drug world.
We're too fired up pilot.
Look, I didn't say how I got my license.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
There you go.
I found it.
Guys, I found the airport.
Can
I do it?
Oh my god.
I'm a certified pilot.
Look at that!
A bee!
Why would I deserve a bee?
That was just turbulence.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
How come turbulence affected my...
my grade?
That's not fair!
Alright.
Altitude refers to the aircraft's nose position relative to the horizon.
There's three pitch altitudes controlled by the elevator.
And in this lesson, you will learn to climb, cruise, and descend.
I don't need to learn how to do that.
I just go up and down.
The bee for Toekeeper.
Bee for best pilot.
Exactly.
That's why I got a bee.
You're telling how good I was at flying this plane.
It was so majestic.
Okay.
I don't feel comfortable when my pilot has these three lines on the plane.
Before you get on the plane, make sure your plane doesn't have these three lines drawn on there.
Because that means it might be driven by Toekeeper.
Hahaha.
Let's dig deeper into what that means.
Pull back gently on the yoke until the climb horizon.
Then maintain that attitude.
Oh!
I see.
According to your altimeter, we're gaining altitude.
Oh, that's my altitunary.
Proving you can't avoid basic physics while making a climb.
Wait, I need no physics?
I need no math to be a pilot?
Excellent.
Okay.
Our speed is increasing and our altitude is stable.
Alright.
That's why you don't migrate like other birds.
Because I like to stay inside.
The altitude line matches the horizon.
Then maintain that attitude.
The attitude?
Okay.
I thought it was altitude.
On to the horizon for ten seconds.
Okay.
Our altitude is decreasing while our speed is picking up.
Oh my god.
I have to look at all these fucking circles.
That's too many circles to look at.
I have to look.
I wanna enjoy the scenery.
We're gonna cruise altitude-ly.
Your speed is decreasing and your altitude is stable.
That's okay.
Try to make only small adjustments to your pitch to avoid overcorrection.
Am I doing it?
I did it.
Those are small.
Alright.
Would you be comfortable if your pilot was like a B student?
I don't know, man.
I mean, it's B for best, right?
That's how the markings go.
A is alright.
B for best.
C for completionist.
D for done job.
Good.
Alright.
Turns.
Oh my god.
I can do barrel rolls.
I'm gonna learn how to do...
Pal-ta-tay.
See?
D for Dokie.
Yeah, D for Dokie.
Weeee!
I don't know...
I donno what I expected.
I don't know.
I thought I'd be different.
I...
hours...
I really thought this would be different.
Okay, but what if I do this while pulling up?
Maybe it'll be better.
Up!
I did it!
Oh my g- guys!
Guys, I did it!
Guys!
Did you guys see that?
Oh my god!
With the risk of your lives!
I did it!
I pulled it off!
Okay.
I did it.
I'm a professional already.
Is this the Doki Doki Bird Flight Airport?
Sounds horrific!
Thank you for the super chat, Zlack.
Thank you.
Why are you doing this?
What the fuck is that?
Okay.
Air Travel, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I've flown a real Cessna 152, except it was an Autobot.
No, 152 is so easy.
It's so easy to fly, especially in slow flight and sleep turns.
See, guys?
This is so easy!
That's basically what they're saying.
So thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What they're saying is I'm doing a great job.
I'm doing amazing right now.
That's exactly what the super chat implies.
Right.
Maintaining it right now?
That's good.
Yay!
I'm working to maintain a constant...
How do I land my plane?
Level up.
Wee.
You put your plane in a dangerous situation.
Oh.
Level us back out now.
Oh, now she takes control!
Okay, not gonna lie, she should have taken control before I did my barrel roll.
Additional practice will help, don't worry.
I like how now she fucking takes control of the plane.
Small corrections on the yoke will lead to more accurate turns.
Am I leveled?
Accurate turns.
I think I can.
I did it!
C!
Oh, for completionist.
For...
Uh...
Completionist guy.
C for completionist, guys.
I did a great job, thank you, instructor.
All right, what's this?
Power settings, the basics, straight level, altitude, okay, I feel like I don't need a note of basic handling anymore.
I feel like it's all about taking...
Takeoff and landing.
And then after that, I should be fine.
Oh, airliner trainer.
Okay, we're gonna go with...
I don't need to know basic stuff anymore.
I just need to know how to take off.
Fire space to the runway, takeoff.
And then I'll figure out landing later.
I'm gonna do takeoff and then we're gonna figure out landing on the go.
We're gonna figure out landing live.
All we need to know is how to take off the plane.
Alright, Texas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, I gotta get more immersive for that.
Okay.
Is it clear?
I don't think there's anybody here.
I think they know I'm flying a plane today.
Yeah, I think they know I'm flying today.
Alright.
Yeah, seems clear.
Yeah.
Alright.
Slightly increase the power.
That should be good.
And then we're gonna go to the center of the...
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Guys, guys, it wasn't slight!
Guys, guys, it wasn't...
Okay, I'm gonna figure this...
Because I realized it was not slight.
It was not slight chat.
Okay.
Right there.
Guys, guys, guys, guys!
Guys, why is it not turning?!
Guys!
The trees!
Oh, okay, okay.
There you start.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank God my co-pilot...
Oh, my co-pilot took control.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, my God, my co-pilot exactly took control of my way.
And she let me know, did I not hear you?
Guys, guys, guys.
That's what I have to do anyways.
They're suffer under the sort of me.
Yeah, totally.
Do you remember what you told me like guys.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
You keep trying and you keep trying.
I do though, I do!
No, stop!
Is this center?
Is this...
Guys, am I in the center?
Guys, I don't think I'm in the center.
Guys...
Brakes...
How do I...
How do I get the brakes?
AHHHHH!
How do I...
How do I do the brakes?
Okay.
Alright, we're going.
... with the center line.
Then stop your plane just after the number 21.
Oh!
Where's 21?
Guys!
I think I passed 21!
I think I...
But it's okay, I'm in the center now.
I'm in the center though!
Guys, I think 21 is like way behind me.
Not gonna lie.
Maybe I can turn around.
Maybe the copilot will take me back to the Let me be...
Ma'am!
Take me back!
Take me... Oh!
Oh!
Go back in position.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, okay, nevermind.
I collided with the object.
Okay, this time I got it.
Oh my god, this was a brake.
Oh, this is a brake.
Okay.
What power am I on?
I'm on 7%.
Okay.
Nobody here.
Guys, I remember how to use the brake.
Look, look, see?
Am I ready?
Guys, I remember.
Okay.
Look left.
I did it.
Thanks for flying with Doki Airlines.
Come on, thank you Superchallenge.
Thank you.
Maybe if I just do a little...
Okay.
Maybe I have like 24.
There you go.
This should be the center now.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm reading.
I told you.
All I need to do is learn...
I just need to learn...
I just need to learn how to take off.
We're gonna learn how to land while we're on...
in the air.
Okay.
Brake.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're doing it.
Slowly.
Come on.
We're slowly getting there.
All right.
Slow and steady.
Slow and steady, Doki.
You have multiple crashes now.
All right.
Here you go.
And then...
Is that it?
Yeah.
We're gonna take off.
We got pie-full power.
She gave me permission.
Oh my god.
I'm in the center.
Oh.
Stay on the center line.
And keep pushing power until you reach 55 knots.
We're 55.
Now slowly taxi onto the runway and align the plane with the center line.
Then stop your plane just after the number 21.
Oh.
This is so...
Whoa.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, it's okay.
We don't...
Guys.
Okay.
Pull back on the yoke to take off.
There we go.
Yay!
Togi trip.
We're doing it!
We're in the air!
We're 75.
I know I'm 75.
Oh.
75.
Okay.
Where am I?
5000?
I don't know where's 5000.
Oh.
I want to turn on the heat though.
My butt is getting a little cold.
Yeah!
Okay.
Then we're going to turn on the lights.
Yeah!
And then...
Oh.
I need to pull up.
Maintain heading...
What's 210 degrees?
Is this 210?
Oh.
It's okay.
It's fine.
Oh.
There we go.
What speed am I on?
I'm learning!
Am I getting higher?
Oh my god.
I'm getting higher!
Look!
Look at all these people down there!
Who are very safe!
Look at them!
They're so...
They're so safe right now.
I don't know.
I always like get scared when like...
Whenever...
I never want to live close to an airport.
Well to be fair, other than like the noises and stuff...
But like...
I always get... like when the plane...
When you hear the plane landing...
Like hear the plane in the sky and you're like...
Nocturne, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Flying?
She's not even forklift certified.
Yeah!
Woo!
Yay!
Alright, I think we're ready.
I think we're ready guys.
I want to make sure I can handle like an actual aircraft.
Air line training.
Alright, this is it.
This is like...
We need to learn how to take off for this.
And then we're gonna be ready.
We just have to be able to drive a plane.
Alright, here we go.
We just need to be able to drive a real plane.
A real fucking plane.
Not the baby planes.
Oh wait, what the fuck.
Where's the wheel?
Where the fuck...
What happened to the wheel?
Where are all these buttons?
I'm gonna sit in the middle.
Oh, we have autopilot!
Alright, we're sitting in the middle.
We're gonna be both pilot and co-pilot.
MCDU?
Numbers?
PFD?
What are these words?
Or, this is like going from one ear to the other.
I can't register what she's telling me to do.
I don't need to save fuel, is it that?
We don't need to save fuel.
What is this?
Move both thrust levers gently forward to 50% and 1.
Is that 50%?
Then move that to the flex detent.
Move thrust levers to selected takeoff thrust by pressing A.
Is that...
Is that it?
Am I doing it?
Did I...
Did I do it?
Am I gonna fly now?
Is that the ocean?
Oh, we're fly... we're flying!
Guys!
Guys, we're flying!
Overspeed.
What does that mean?
I'm not on the rudder.
I'm not on... Oh hey, there's people.
Oh autopilot.
Look at city.
What the...
Climb?
Press B?
What?
What's over speeding?
I don't know!
What is over speeding?
Over speed.
I'm like what?
What does that mean?
Where's my flight attendant?
I did it.
Oh wait, I did not do it.
What?
How did I fail?
It means over speed.
At 10,000 feet or 4,000 meters, once over the target, roll over and cut the throttle.
Pull stick up to 90 angle degree.
Hold on to...
Thank you for the super chat.
Guys, I think I'm ready.
Guys.
Guys, I think I'm actually ready guys.
For real this time.
Okay, we're gonna grab a...
We're gonna grab a real plane.
A real person plane.
Wait, do I not have the real planes?
Oh no, it's up here.
Okay, air... wait.
Is that a real plane?
Oh my god, the Boeing!
We're grabbing a real plane.
Okay, and then that's gonna be my plane.
I think I learned enough.
Guys.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can be green!
I can be blue.
I can be...
Oh my god, the aviators club!
Alright, here.
I'm gonna be that plane.
And then...
I'm gonna do...
Wait, I can customize?
Flight number!
Okay.
My flight number will be...
Okay, I was gonna write it really fucked up.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Alright, there we go.
That's gonna be my flight number.
Oh no!
No!
My flight!
Okay, there we go.
Alright, we're gonna...
Where should we go to?
Let's see.
We should go to...
Who wants me to...
Be at their airport?
I can't move.
Okay.
Whoa!
That was a weird globe spin.
Oh my god, I should fly at night time.
Alright, the UK.
Nothing bad happens in the UK.
Glasgow.
Alright, we're gonna...
Departure Glasgow.
And then we're gonna head over to...
We're gonna head over...
Oh my god, wait.
What's this?
We could go to...
We're gonna go to...
You know what?
Let's go to...
Let's go to Germany.
Alright.
Arrival.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright, EU goons.
This is for you!
Ow!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What could possibly... Exactly!
What could possibly go wrong?
Is that Germany?
That's Belgium.
Sorry.
My European...
This is for you, EU goons!
As I ruin geography.
We're going to Belgium!
They know German there too!
They're like...
They know German, French, and English because they're squashed up by like several other countries.
Is that Belgium or is that a different country?
No, I should be right.
Because we all know I'm great at geography.
Okay.
Alright, don't worry EU goons!
As I mess up!
Oh my god!
Where are the lights?
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Um...
Where can I turn on the light?
Give me a sec.
The pilot...
There's buttons behind me?!
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Why is there buttons behind me?
Okay.
Um, no.
I'm gonna put...
I'm gonna put my brake back on.
No, it'll be fine.
Okay.
Um...
Oh my god, there's a yoke!
Oh my god, how do I turn on the lights?
Okay.
Guys, I'm trying to figure out how to turn on the lights right now.
Give me a sec.
Okay, that's...
Oh!
Instrument lighting.
Okay, that's already at 100.
Okay.
Map brightness.
Inoperative.
Okay.
NDF brightness.
How do I...
How do I turn on the lights above me?
Guys.
The captain needs some help right now.
I need more lights.
Press F for flashlights.
Guys.
Oh my god.
Maybe I shouldn't have driven at night time.
Guys, I realized night time was the...
mistake.
Oh, I could get the ATC on.
Okay, alright.
ATC, tell me what to do.
Flight Assistant.
Okay, Flight Assistant.
That's not assisting me right now.
Alright, let's see.
What is that?
Is that the map?
Oh my god, that's where we are.
Let's put the map here.
This is where like all the overlays are out for us too.
The checklist, the basic control, travel to, weather.
Alright, and then... Okay guys, we're gonna change the date.
We're gonna... Guys, I realize...
Let's make it the morning now.
We're gonna adjust everything here.
Alright, and then... Let's see.
Oh, what is this?
Okay, we're gonna put that here as well.
And then... What's this?
The camera.
What's the camera?
What is the camera?
Okay, I found the light switch.
That's why I was thinking about the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, your captain is figuring out the controls.
She's gonna block the entire screen.
Alright.
Alright guys, don't worry.
I turned on... I found the light switch, chat!
Chat, I found the light switch.
I turned on it.
I found the sun!
I did it!
Alright.
Do I... What's the camera, chat?
What is that?
The main light?
The light switch of the Earth?
Okay.
Okay, now I can't see my plane anymore.
Uhhhh...
Oh, is it... Do I take pictures of me driving the plane with the camera?
Okay.
Um... Oh guys, I think it was a bad idea for having all these overlays.
I need to put... Turn off these overlays, chat.
Guys, I think it was a bad idea.
We don't need the ATC.
Alright, I think we're ready.
Guys, I think we're ready.
Okay, give me an immerse.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Let me... Let me pull something up real quick.
Uh...
Alright, give me a sec, guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me pull something up real quick.
Okay.
Um...
Alright, are you guys ready for the immersion?
Um... Ladies and gentlemen, uh... Welcome aboard to Flight 69.
Uh... We're serviced from... Where are we?
Glasgow to, uh... Brussels.
We're currently third in line for takeoff and are expected to be in the air in approximately, uh...
We ask that you please fasten your seat belts at this time and, uh...
Secure all baggages underneath your seat or in your, uh... Overhead compartments.
Uh... We also ask that your seats and table trays are in the upright position for takeoff.
Uh... Please turn off your seat belts.
Turn off all...
Please turn on all personal electronic devices and, uh... Including laptops and cell phones.
So you can be sure to have Doki Bird on your screen watching her, uh... Drive this plane.
Smoking is allowed for the duration of the flight, uh... Because she likes the challenge.
Thank you for choosing Doki Airlines and enjoy your flight.
Okay, okay, okay.
Sorry.
Uh... Good afternoon, passengers.
That was the flight attendant announcement.
I am also your flight attendant and your pilot.
Just do not worry.
When our pilot starts in, I'm gonna start serving you guys drinks.
Anyway, this is your captain speaking now.
First, I'd like to welcome everyone on, uh... On the Doki Airlines Flight 69.
We're currently at... We're currently not cruising at any altitude.
Uh... The time is... Uh... We've, like, turned on the sun and the time should be around 6.45 a.m.
Uh... The weather looks good!
When the tailwind outside, we're expected to land in... In... In... In Brussels.
In Brussels, approximately, uh... 15 hours behind schedule.
Uh...
Sit back, relax, and enjoy the rest of the flight.
Alright, I think we're good.
I think we're good.
I think the passengers are okay, chat.
I think the passengers know what's up.
Alright, guys.
This is it.
We've trained for this.
Dragoons, we've trained for this.
Am I on?
Apply throw throttle.
Alright.
That should be full.
Oh, that's a lot of numbers going up.
Woah.
Alright.
We're just gonna keep the aircraft straight.
That was a lot of numbers that I saw going up.
But that should be good.
One Doki airline ticket, please.
See?
Thank you for the matcha soup.
Thank you.
People believe in me.
Alright.
We're good?
It's 104.
Okay, we're pretty sure all of these are up.
Oh, I forgot.
There we go.
I had my brakes on.
Do not worry.
The pilot knows what she's doing.
Alright, here we go.
Yay!
Am I in the center?
I am, right?
This has to be the center, right?
Yeah!
Agent, thank you for the matcha soup.
Let me look away from...
Okay, raise aircraft nose and lift off.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We're doing it.
We're going higher.
There's no overdrive.
We're going higher now.
Alright.
It's fine.
Raise landing gear.
What the fuck is landing gear?
You love it when you hear your pilot say what the fuck is landing gear.
Can I...
How do I turn on autopilot?
Is the autopilot on?
Do I have to drive this myself now?
I can't believe my captain is my OSHA.
We're not gonna make it, bros.
But it's been an amazing ride!
What the fuck?
Where are you believers?
Oh.
Where are my believers in chat?
Glasgow Tower, Boeing Alpha Sierra.
747 frequency change.
Am I going up?
747 is tight.
Boeing B748, four miles southwest of Glasgow.
2,400 feet.
Am I doing it?
I don't need clearance.
I'm DokiBird.
Boeing Alpha Sierra, 747 class.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Boeing 747.
Cleared through the Charlie airspace.
I think we're okay, right?
Cleared through the Charlie airspace, Boeing 747.
I did it!
They cleared us!
Guys, they cleared us!
Guys, the turbulence!
Passengers, please remain in your seats.
We're experiencing some mass turbulence right now.
So do not worry.
This is just turbulence.
It's not the pilot doing a funky dr- Oh my god!
Okay, we gotta go higher.
I wanna do a barrel roll.
On my- There's this like, famous like fucking video where like, uh, passengers were gonna perform a sick barrel roll right now.
Wait, let me see if I can pull it up.
Wait, I'm gonna find it.
Okay guys, I'm tabbing it.
I think I should be fine.
I think my plane will be okay.
Okay.
Uh...
Let me see if I can find that audio clip.
Pilot...
Pilot, okay.
Uh, audio.
Oh my god, it was like, so long ago.
Okay.
It was like, airplane...
Um...
Oh, I don't remember where it is!
No!
I don't remember what it's called!
Oh no.
Oh shit, okay.
Don't worry, we're fine!
I tapped out, it's fine!
Did he just say goodbye?
We're fine.
Does anyone remember that audio clip?
It was from Tumblr.
By the way.
For anyone- The audio clip of the fucking guy that was pretending to be a pilot and he's like, Don't worry passengers, we're gonna perform a sick barrel roll.
I hear you.
See, I told you!
We're fine!
You can use your phone and...
And...
See?
Look!
Everybody's okay!
Where the fuck is my food, flight attendant?
Alright.
Can't wait for me to- Oh god, I just remember we never learned how to land.
We never learned how- Guys!
I just realized we never learned how to land the plane.
We'll be fine!
We're losing altitude?
How do you know I'm losing altitude?
I can barely read any of these.
Is it cause I'm going down?
Good day.
How do you- You're stoked out.
Oh, they're saying goodbye!
Glasgow approach Boeing Alpha Sierra.
74710- Is that me?
Oh, that's me!
Boeing Alpha 2
radar contact.
I think we're fine.
Like, we're like 420- Oh, I should've- I should've selected a closer place.
It's way too loud.
Good day.
Okay, I'm gonna pull up...
and then I'm gonna tab out.
We're fine!
Boeing Alpha Sierra.
74710- We should be fine.
...
Does it- Can you tell that I'm not tabbed into the game yet?
Can you tell?
We're fine!
Everybody's fine!
Stop panicking!
Guys, look!
We're okay!
Why is everybody panicking?
...
Boeing Alpha Sierra.
74711- We didn't learn to land.
I think that's like the worst part.
Boeing Alpha Sierra.
74711- Press quick approach altimeter.
2-9-10- I think the worst part is that we actually did not learn how to land this plane.
So like, that's gonna be...
That's gonna be an issue for us later on.
We actually forgot to learn how to...
land the plane.
Boeing Alpha Sierra.
875.
Boeing 747- Guys!
Why did you guys forgot to teach me how to land the plane?
We all had one job!
Boeing Alpha Sierra.
747- Scottish Central Altimeter.
This is so far away.
I'm just gonna land here on the Stonehill Farm.
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna land here.
Alright, I'm gonna land in the Stonehill Farm airstrip.
This is way too far.
I chose the...
The destination I chose was way too far.
This is gonna take us forever!
It's like 414 like...
something meters!
To the farm we go.
Wait, how do I use autopilot?
I forgot how to use the autopilot.
Which button is that?
Is this?
Did I click autopilot?
I think I did.
Did I do it?
No, I don't want autopilot.
Okay.
I don't know what I pressed.
Wait, am I high enough for a barrel roll?
Okay, guys.
The moment we get closer...
What did I click?
Were we sideways?
The autopilot tried to realign me.
So I'm like, oh my god.
Was I unaligned this entire time?
Please go higher?
But why?
It doesn't matter.
There's no people down there.
There might be people in the flame.
There's no people.
There's no people down there.
They don't care.
I'm flying.
There's still 400 away?
Oh my god.
This is going to take forever.
Bro.
Oh.
I'm just saying.
We all have to...
We all have like important appointments.
Okay.
I'm thinking of a super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine you're flying.
Let's set the IRL.
I'll just land here in the middle of nowhere.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, don't keep my flight at speed of heart.
Please don't give me anxiety.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do you mean?
I am fucking flying perfectly.
Look.
Everybody's...
Everything's fine.
Chat.
Everything.
Make sure you have your electronic devices on with Wi-Fi on too so you can watch a Doki Bird stream.
Okay.
All right, guys.
I think we're doing pretty well.
See?
Am I high enough in the sky?
I should be higher.
Like, I don't think it's good that I can see the city.
Like, I don't think...
I just realized.
I just realized it might not be a good thing that the city is like in my view.
So maybe I should be a little higher.
I feel like...
Right?
Yeah.
I should not be able to see the city.
Wait.
Are the gears down?
What does that mean?
What do you mean?
What altitude am I on?
Does it tell me what altitude I'm on?
Why is it only at two?
Okay.
There it is.
I see it's at the bottom right.
You don't see it, but I see the altitude.
I'm going to keep pulling up until the altitude...
Oh.
What's that sound?
That's a good job sound, right?
That should be the good job.
Okay.
I'm like 16,000.
Here we go.
All right.
I'm at 17,000 altitude now.
Here we go.
All right.
This is good.
That's good.
I should be higher, though.
I feel like I should be at like 20K, right?
Half the fuel.
It's been half the fuel this entire time.
Okay, I should be...
Guys.
Guys, what is the optimal amount of altitude that I should be on?
Because I'm at 17,000 right now.
30k?
Okay, we're so fucking far.
Can I turn on my autopilot?
Is my autopilot on?
No.
Is my autopilot?
What is my autopilot doing?
What is it doing?
Why is it going down?
Autopilot, go back up.
Where is my autopilot doing?
I turned off autopilot because I couldn't tell what they're doing.
I couldn't tell what it's doing.
It was going down!
It's flying around, but it's right there.
It's right in front of me.
Why would it change its course?
Here's to your heading and altitude.
The altitude?
But we have to go up.
We need to go up.
I am doing a better job than... I wonder what does these do?
I wonder what happens if I turn on all of these.
What's this?
Oh, that's the brakes.
I should not touch that.
But like, what are all these buttons though?
The rudder trim?
What does this do?
That's not good, right?
Oh, turn on your seat belts, everybody!
Turn off your seat belts!
Wait.
Off.
I'm gonna turn it off.
Guys, turn off your seat belts!
Oh, that's how they do it!
Oh!
Guys, we're at 20k!
Guys, oh my god.
Guys, we're at 20k, guys.
Okay.
Alright, and then, what is this?
Okay, that's the seat belts are off.
That's good.
That's all we wanted.
And then... where are these buttons?
Where are these buttons, dude?
Am I... Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
I just have to be sure.
I have to be sure that we're okay.
Oh, that's way too close.
I don't wanna look at the controls like that.
Oh my god, it's still so far!
Oh, let me fix the controls here.
There we go.
Alright.
Wait, where the fuck is the... where are we?
Okay, and then, we're gonna...
Let's see...
Where are all these other buttons, though?
Transporter mode...
TA...
I know what these buttons does, but they look cool.
Oooh!
This is like radio...
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
There we go.
Sorry, I just realized that my things started going... wait, what about the controls above me?
What are these?
Oh, cabin temperature!
There we go.
I gotta make sure we're extra nice and cozy.
And then... there we go.
Now that seems better.
There we go.
Now everybody is nice and cozy.
And then... what do all these buttons do?
Cover?
What the fuck does cover do?
That's what you want to hear your pilot say.
What the fuck do all these buttons do?
Cabin temperature, cargo temperature...
APU starter...
Oh!
It's to... oh!
That'll be fun, right?
Oh!
Whoa!
Is everything okay?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, is everything okay?
It's fine, we're fine.
What do you mean we're gonna crash?
Did I turn off the engine?
Oh, did I turn off... oh, what did I press?
Oh, I turned off the engine!
Ah!
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine!
We're still in the air!
Guys!
How do I turn it back on?!
I pressed so many buttons!
Guys.
How do I... what did I press?
Is it the battery?
Where is it?
Where is the battery?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, where is it?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Did I do it?
Did I turn it back on?
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay guys.
Nothing bad is gonna happen.
Guys, none of the lights are on.
I don't know why I should be alarmed, but all the lights are off.
Okay.
I don't know why I should be alarmed.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh, oh, oh, I turned it on.
Oh!
Guys, we're okay.
We're okay guys.
Guys, they locked my thing.
Guys, I think the autopilot went on automatically.
Wait, are my engines off?
Where's the engines?
Battery, AC, generator, on, on, on, on, on.
Everything's on.
119er, decimal 875, Boeing 747.
Scottish Centre, Boeing Alpha Sierra, 747.
8,600 feet.
Middle?
Why did I turn it off?
I pressed so many buttons.
I turned off so many buttons.
Guys, I don't know why I turned it off.
There were so many buttons, guys.
Oh, the throttle is down!
Here we go.
It won't let me fly anymore.
Can I turn the autopilot off?
Is it because I have autopilot on?
They're not letting me have control of the plane!
Guys, caution!
We don't have control of the plane anymore!
Okay, we have to figure out which is the engine.
We're just gliding.
I can't... where the fuck is the engine?
APU generator?
Where the fuck is that?
They didn't teach me this at pilot school!
APU, APU.
Where the fuck is... Oh, there it is!
Oh, it is on!
Oh!
Did I turn it on?
I have it on!
On.
Are we okay?
We're sort of off course.
We're so off course.
It is!
It's on!
I turned it on!
Everything is on!
I hit the ignition?
Where the fuck is that?
There's a TV?
Guys, I don't... I think we're off course.
We're so off course.
Guys, our altitude is going down.
Guys, our altitude is going down!
Oh, no!
We're gonna be okay!
I can't!
It's not... The autopilot won't let me pull up!
Oh, no!
We're... Okay, okay, we're gonna figure this out.
We're gonna save the day!
Oh, my God!
Where the fuck is the engine?
Closed.
Oh, no.
We're at 2000 altitude, guys.
We're at 2000... Closed?
Open?
Is that it?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh...
Oh!
Guys, it was...
Guys, we hit the ocean!
That...
Guys!
Oh, no!
Guys, we're gonna land safely!
It's gonna be so safe!
300, 200, 100...
We're safe.
We're so safe.
Guys, we're so... We're so okay.
We are so okay.
We're so... We're so okay!
Guys, the plane is still intact!
The plane is still intact!
End of flight.
Guys, see?
Everything is okay.
Um...
Dude...
...
To automatically reset the aircraft in the air?
It's like nothing bad happened.
Hello.
...
Um.
Um, passengers.
Welcome to Dokey flight 69.
Saved.
It was just really bad turbulence, chat.
Just incredibly terrible turbulence.
I should have gone faster.
All I'm saying is the plane was not on fire.
We got saved.
Okay, we're gonna reach it.
We still have three...
Alright, we gotta go up though.
We're gonna go all the way up.
We gotta go up.
We're gonna hit like what?
30k?
Look, we have engines now!
I don't know what I turned off.
Agent, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We're gonna have to relive this for...
No, we're fine!
Doki Airlines knows exactly what she's doing.
No refunds.
You already paid.
There's no refunds on this flight, chat.
Okay, here we go.
We're just gonna go slowly up.
Slowly higher.
How do I change the...
Okay, we're gonna go slowly higher, guys.
This plane will not crash when I'm on the pilot seat.
I gotta figure out how to land this plane though.
I skipped that in my...
My teachers felt like I was doing so well that...
Oh, wait, wait.
Can I do a barrel roll right now?
I should be able to, right?
How far am I?
Okay, at 10,000 altitude, I'm gonna try to do the barrel roll.
It should be fine, right?
At 10,000 altitude?
Guys, it should be fine.
Nice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for the nightmare.
We're gonna be okay!
We're gonna be so healthy!
It'll be so funny!
Okay, we're gonna do it at 10.
That should be enough altitude.
That should be enough, right?
Right, guys?
That should be enough.
Oh, what's that sound?
What's that sound mean?
Oh, oh.
Okay, ready?
Watch this.
Guys, this is a lot slower than I expected.
We're still at 11,000 altitude!
Good day to you too, ma'am!
Oh, oh!
Oh!
We gotta pull up!
We got 1
,000!
Pull up, pull up, pull up, pull up, pull up!
Pull up, pull up!
We're okay, we're okay, we're okay, we're okay!
We're okay!
Oh, my God!
I told you we're- I told you 10- Oh, my- I am a fucking prodigy.
Passengers, make sure to fasten your seat belts.
We are going- We're in really, really, really bad turbulence there.
But it is okay.
We hope you enjoy your flight.
And Doki Airlines, thank you!
Guys, oh, my God!
That turbulence was fucking crazy, though.
Am I going up?
I'm going up, right?
Yeah.
That turbulence was insane.
AirTrap, you fly in Microsoft flights in the future.
Will you do crew flights?
I'd love to, Joe.
Joanne, duh.
I'll be adhering to VATS and real charts and such.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
There's multiplayer?
In this game?
What the fuck's the multiplayer do?
The fucking...
Multiplayer co-capt- Oh, my God!
Does that mean, like, I could accidentally hit another plane?
That's so scary.
Oh, my God.
That's so fucking scary.
Jesus Christ, it's like PvP, but with planes.
We're not stalling.
We should be fine.
Why is my engine going down?
Is my engine okay?
Hahaha!
Should I be worried that my engine is going down?
Should I be worried about that?
Also, like, if I have a co-pilot, I feel like my co-pilot will stop me from...
will stop me from doing the right thing.
Because the...
Hahaha!
Guys, did you see that sick barrel roll that I did, though?
That's so fucking...
I still have 341!
That's it!
I'm landing my plane closer!
There has to be an airport closer.
I still remember this as the day the collective lifespan of all dragoons was reduced by 10 meters.
Thank you for the six-time thing.
Goodbye.
Why did I pick somewhere so far away?
It's so far!
I only, like, fucking did a hundred fucking meters!
Hey, agent, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As an aircraft mechanic, you're not the worst pilot.
That is, like, a bit concerning, not gonna lie.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That is, like, just a little bit concerning that I'm not the worst one.
Alright.
Let me, like, make sure you guys don't fasten your seat belts, too.
Um...
Where was the seat belt thing?
Here you go.
Seat belts.
Oh, seat belts already off!
Good.
That's good to know.
I already thought about your safety.
What do all these buttons do?
So, what do these buttons do?
Oh, no.
Go back up.
Need a throttle.
Okay.
I'm gonna keep going.
Just a little.
Wait, 15k altitude?
That's not...
Oh, but what if...
Okay, I'm gonna drive lower.
I think it'll be so funny.
If I drive, like...
What is, like, the lowest that I can go, like, altitude-wise?
Like, 10k?
Or 5k?
What's the lowest?
Oh, be immersive!
Above the ground.
Okay.
Does that affect my speed?
It's not like it's gonna affect my speed anyway.
I still have, like, 330.
It's so far.
It's so...
Pay for altitude.
Sorry, guys.
You cheapen out.
Doki Airlines, you guys... you guys cheapen out on the tickets.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we're landing our plane on fucking Peter Lee Airfield.
This is way too far.
Alright.
Fine!
We'll go to the air...
We'll go to this airline.
We'll go to your original destination.
Oh, lower... the higher altitude, the faster?
Guys, you should have said that in the first place.
Then I'll go higher.
There you go.
Alright, we're gonna go to...
Guys, you tell me that earlier!
If I knew that earlier...
Incorrect high altitude.
How do I reset that?
Am I... am I okay?
I'm fine!
Don't answer that.
Alright, we're going to Space.
We're going to the Moon.
Hello, passengers.
There has been a...
There has been a correction regarding our flight path.
We are now going to the Moon.
Thank you.
And we hope you enjoy your time at Doki Airlines.
Alright, now they'll know.
Oh, what's that sound?
I don't like it when I don't know what the sound is.
No, we missed... No, our airport's still there!
We just need to go higher!
To the moon we go!
Doki, you need an altitude adjustment.
What does that even mean?
Thank you, Little Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Black.
Alright.
I wonder, let me go higher.
Oh, I don't like that sound.
Alright.
You're in the airliner?
Enter price!
Thank you, Little Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, I'm in the airliner, but it's important because I have passengers on my plane.
Um, those are slow.
Flight airplanes are fast fly.
Also, do you ever put the landing gear up?
That is a really good question.
We should change our POV to...
You know, guys, I'm actually curious.
Did I?
How do I check?
Guys, how do I...
Guys, where do I check regarding, like, my POV?
Is it the camera?
How do I change my POV, chat?
Guys, how do I change the POV?
That's a very... Is it the camera?
Okay.
External.
Alright, let's check.
No, see!
Look!
I did it!
I know what I'm doing.
Guys, I know exactly what I'm doing.
Alright, let's just look up from here.
There we go.
Whoa!
The turbulence is hitting hard.
Look at that.
Whoa!
Guys, sorry about the turbulence, guys.
Alright, nice.
We should be fine.
Whoa!
We need to go up the altitude.
We're still, like... We're at 18K right now.
Can I, like, make sure our engine is higher?
There we go.
We gotta go at least 30K, right?
30K is the...
I can still see the city, though.
I'm gonna make sure we don't see the city.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm at full speed now.
Alright.
What's the best 30K, right?
Alright, we're at 20K.
Up we go!
Oh my gosh.
It's a party up here!
Don't worry.
It's fine.
It's not stalling.
At all.
Alright, 20K is good.
It can be higher, right?
My lunch!
Guys, I'm sorry.
We're late.
We're experiencing some really, really, really bad turbulence.
Are the engines supposed to be near red?
Yeah.
We wanna be faster and higher.
35K is the norm?
Okay, we're gonna go up.
To the moon we go.
We go higher.
I wanted to get up.
Jokey for spooky ride.
Look, we're going faster!
We're going higher!
We're at 23K!
Let's go!
I think we can go higher.
We're going even higher.
Full speed engine.
We have so much fuel!
We're still only at 50% fuel!
24K.
Oh my god, we're gonna be so high up now.
30K.
We're gonna go to space.
Can we actually go to space?
What happens if we go to like 40?
How many altitude is space?
Many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, incorrect.
Oh my gosh, what do you mean incorrect?
Incorrect high altitude altitude.
Oh, oh, I don't like that.
Okay, here we go.
Don't worry.
I like it still.
We're still gonna go up.
Okay.
We still need to go up guys.
We're not there yet.
Space is 100.
Oh my, can I reach 100?
Is that possible?
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As someone who just recently been on a flight for the first time, is now obsessed with planes.
I love this.
You wish you had a pilot like me, right?
Thank you.
It's only dropped down like 10 since...
Oh my, I thought you said the higher we go.
The higher we go.
The faster we get.
I feel like...
I feel like we're still like super fucking slow.
45 Ks on max.
Fucking cowards.
Actual cowards.
Oh my God.
We are like 290 now.
This is gonna take fucking forever.
Who told me to fly to Belgium?
Belgium!
Who the fuck told me to do that?
Oh my God.
I'm just gonna go higher still.
We're gonna go up.
Higher.
We're gonna go all the way to 30.
And then...
We're gonna go all the way to 30 and then we go back in the cockpit.
How am I not moving?
Is it because like...
Oh I...
Woah.
So all the luggage is on the tail now?
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
That should be good.
We should be good now, right?
Now that we're at 30?
Yeah, alright.
We can change the camera now.
Alright, camera.
Cockpit.
There we go.
Nice.
We did it.
Yeah, we fucking did it.
Look at us go.
We're so good at this whole plane thing.
Good thing the passengers didn't...
didn't put on their seat belts.
Alright, that's it.
I'm fucking...
Alright.
That's fucking it.
How do I turn on autopilot?
Is this it?
Can I turn it on?
Why is whenever I turn on autopilot it just goes to the right?
Why did I do that?
Every time...
Every time I turn on autopilot it flies to the right.
No, it's not.
I'm fucking putting it on.
I don't like that.
We have to...
We have to go here.
I have to program the autopilot?
Then what's the point of having autopilot if I have to program it myself?
What's the point of having AI if I still have to do my own job?
Like...
Oh, hey, is that the landing gear?
Oh, okay.
We figured it out.
We know where the landing gear is.
Alright.
Guys, there is a chance that this pilot might just land in the ocean.
There is...
There is a slight possibility.
There is a very...
Judging by how far left we have, there is a great possibility that she is gonna land in the ocean because she does not have enough time before her meeting on YouTube.
Just a little bit.
Just a little possibility.
We're not sure yet.
We're not...
But like...
Judging by how fast we're going, which is not as fast as I would have liked...
Uh...
We'll be fine.
I'll have my landing gear on.
Mr. YouTube is waiting right now and like I'm gonna put my la...
Don't worry.
Where's the landing gear?
I saw it.
Here.
There you go.
Landing gear is on.
Uh...
Selected altitude.
I'm gonna go to the next one.
Can I get it higher?
Okay.
Oh!
Is this my autopilot?
Oh my god!
It's 50,000 feet.
That's my selected altitude.
What is this?
Vertical speed?
Okay.
And then...
Are we in the water now?
Is that the water?
This has to be the water.
It's blue.
Oh, this is not the water.
Hahaha!
Let's see.
Oh, okay.
So this is speed, uh, caution.
I'm gonna turn off the caution so I don't see it.
Uh...
If anything bad is going on.
I won't be able to know if anything's bad going on, which would be great for me.
And then...
Uh...
Oh yeah!
We're definitely...
Uh...
Guys!
There is a podcast.
There is a possibility that I'm gonna land right here.
There is a huge possibility but before that.
Okay.
Pilot.
Before that.
I gotta make sure...
Uh...
I'm gonna make sure to warn you guys first.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Uh.....
Hahaha!
Don't worry.
Give me a sec, guys.
I need to make sure that we are...
Alright, we know that we are landing.
Where is the...
Where is the landing script here?
Where the fuck is the landing script?
Safety briefing.
Captain's announcement.
I don't need safety.
We're so safe already!
We're so safe!
Why do I need safe?
Okay, flight...
Flight landing pilot script.
Alright.
Sample radio calls.
Departing.
I don't need to know departing.
I need to know like landing.
Guys, we might be slowly going down, but it'll be okay.
It'll be okay.
Guys, it'll be okay.
We're slightly going down.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm ready chat.
Look, see?
Everything's fine!
Why are you guys freaking out?
Why are you freaking out?
Our landing gear is on!
Let me grab the camera.
Okay, external.
Is my landing gear on?
There we go.
It is.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, chat.
We're fine!
Why are y'all so scared?
I don't understand.
Why are you guys all so scared?
We're so alright.
We're so fine.
Hello.
This is your captain speaking, Do mejoresaan...
This
is your captain speaking, Do kehuj Philippines.
Please ignore that.
To all the passengers who have heard that, please ignore that.
We are doing okay right now.
We are already starting our descent procedure into the ocean.
We expect to land in 10 minutes.
If you want to adjust your watch, it is now 10pm in the ocean now.
The weather in the ocean is quite nice.
It is maybe like 3 degrees in the ocean.
So make sure you have your life jacket on.
We wish you a pleasant stay in the ocean.
And we hope to see you again very soon.
On behalf of our crew, thank you for choosing Doki Airlines as your airline today.
Thank you!
Alright guys!
I think that went well.
Chat?
I think so.
I think that went really well.
Alright, let's go down.
Let's go down.
Alright.
Yeah!
Oh, we are going down down.
Don't worry, we can make this a safe land...
Oh my god!
It is!
To retract... No, no, we are going to have the landing gear of the sea ocean.
We got to land on the ocean.
Oh, it's vibrating guys.
Look.
It will be fine.
2000 altitude.
We are fine.
Look.
See?
Alright.
We are gonna make it.
I think I should be in the cockpit when I land in the ocean.
I don't know what that is like.
Alright.
Look.
See?
Everything is fine.
I don't know why everybody is so worried.
Alright.
Alright, 1000 altitude.
900 800 All your passengers!
That's good!
They get to sleep!
800 We're almost there.
600 500 altitude.
And we gotta make sure...
Woooooo!
Wait, we're going up.
The plane didn't crash.
Look, see?
Everything's fine.
We gotta make sure we're aligning a bit better with the ocean.
Beyond the water doesn't hurt.
Okay, 100.
It's okay, guys.
Just a little bumpy.
The ocean is just a little bumpy, chat.
The o- the water...
Woooooo!
That's okay.
The ocean is just a little...
AI is cra-
Guys, it's okay.
The ocean is just being a little bumpy.
We'll be fine.
It's like landing!
We're okay, guys.
See?
Look.
There we go.
What the fuck does that look like?
Aaaaaaaaah!
We did it!
Um...
We forgot to mention to you that Jesus reincarnated into a plane.
Welcome to the Dochi Airlines Jesus experience.
We did it!
We did it guys!
Shut down air... Oh my god!
It's the end of flight!
How do I shut down the aircraft?
How do I shut it down?
How do I turn off my plane?
Can we turn off my plane?
I guess like...
There we go.
Shut down aircraft systems.
How do I turn off my plane?
Was it when I pressed all these buttons earlier?
Flip all the buttons?
Is that it?
Okay.
There we go.
Shut it down.
Off.
There we go.
I always knew the ocean was...
Yeah!
Jesus took the plane!
We did it!
We shut...
The landing gear worked, chat!
I fucking knew it worked.
What if I did it?
I knew... I knew I was meant to fly.
Yay!
Look at that!
Total time of flight!
We made it in 45 minutes!
Oh my god.
We actually did it.
Jesus literally took the wheel.
We fucking did it, chat.
Didn't they get two in one ticket to Doki Airlines?
And Doki Cruise.
Shady, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
We fucking did it, guys!
Oh my god.
I knew I was meant to drive the plane.
I fucking... Oh my god.
Wait.
Is that a fighter jet?
Okay.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Is that a fighter jet right there?
Oh my god.
This is the right flight.
Okay.
We're not...
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Wait.
Let me fucking get a closer one.
Okay.
Set as departure.
We're gonna do a quick fighter jet.
I think we... I think like we've made it.
I'm gonna... I think we... We definitely made it.
I just wanna know what it's like.
I just wanna know what is this like.
Okay.
We're gonna turn on the sun again.
Wait.
I can't... I can't... I can't drive the plane.
I'm already in the air.
Oh my god.
Bro.
What the fuck?
There's more buttons?
How is there more buttons than the fucking...
What are all these... How are there more buttons?
What are these codes?
How do I shoot... shoot the gun?
Where's the shoot part?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Okay.
How do I shoot the gun?
I wanna shoot... The only reason why...
Oh wait.
Is that the eject button?
Is this eject?
Oh I can't press it.
A lot of these buttons are inoperable, I think.
Yeah.
I wonder why.
I wonder why they're all inoperable.
This thing will be fine.
Tail hook.
Right engine.
Right battery.
Oh!
Okay.
I need to remember not to do that.
The weapons are deactivated?
What's the point if I can't even fucking shoot the plane?
That's fucking it.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe there's no point...
There's no ammo on this plane.
I can't believe it.
Can't fucking believe there's no ammo.
There we go.
Alright.
Alright guys.
I think cruising up here is the way...
I can't even eject it!
What does the third person look like?
Okay.
External.
Oh my god.
I look so cool but I can't shoot in this plane.
I can't believe I can't shoot in this plane.
Weeeeeeeeeeeee.
Weeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee.
I mean can I land it at least?
How do I land this?
How do I land this thing?
Another ocean!
Oh my god, Jesus.
Take the wheel again.
Jesus, take the wheel!
Jesus!
Take the wheel, Jesus!
Weeeeeeeeeeeeeer.
Ohohohoho!
It's okay, everything's fine.
But I should like slow down.
Everything is okay.
We got me a jet!
See?
Jesus!
We'll be fine!
Take the wheel, Jesus!
Woooo!
It's like a bouncy castle!
There's the castle.
Wait, am I...
Okay.
There's like no engine now.
There's the ocean!
Why the fuck do I land this plane?
Don't worry.
We're gonna land very safe.
Yay!
Wherever the plane is.
There it is!
Airspeed too low.
Co-pilot, you don't fucking get to decide what I do!
There we go.
Easy.
We fucking did it, boys!
Look at that!
Here we go.
Jesus plane did it again!
The Jesus plane did it again!
What can she not do?
There we go.
See?
Everything's fine.
Everything's fine now, guys.
Look at that.
Beautiful scenery too.
Very beautiful.
That's fun!
That was really fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed Doki Airlines chat.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize there's just...
I'm surprised my PC was able to stat all that on high settings.
Not gonna lie.
I was like, really worried because everybody was like, oh, this is gonna PC stress test.
I was like, what do you mean a PC stress test?
I don't even have... I didn't even like plug it or take it out of my new PC out of the box yet!
Because it's so much work.
It's so much work.
That was really fun!
I really enjoyed it.
That was like...
I can't believe there's like multiplayer for flight simulator.
I can't believe.
I feel like people will really hate me if I'm on the multiplayer.
Because I don't...
take it seriously.
I feel like I'm just gonna like...
I'm just gonna accidentally hit another plane.
And I'm gonna get yelled at.
I feel like I'm gonna...
I'm just accidentally gonna hit somebody's plane in the sky.
Because I make my own route.
I don't even follow any route.
I just make my own route.
I know.
Also like...
if I have a co-pilot they would definitely not like what I do.
Anyway guys, in 12 minutes I have to go to the YouTube meeting.
But I hope you guys had a fun time watching today.
That was a really fun game.
I definitely enjoyed how immersive it was.
And pressing all those buttons.
I still don't know like 80% of the buttons I pressed today.
I still don't know.
I still don't know 80% of whatever the fuck I pressed today.
But I enjoyed myself.
I enjoyed myself.
Anyway guys, I hope you guys enjoyed Doki Airlines and you would choose our airline again for another flight.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!